come on game day can't really sleep last
night woke up with a brand desire to get
Buttershaw
break it a little bit of breakfast in
right now that one one little walk do
get my day started
I can show charlie
the moment of jail with the game yeah
and a nice outline we grind we grind now
headlights off we still get it in your
ear I don't know what's all about right
beside my brother ray already get how
many here runs away from us one two
three
for more than 30 years aspiring
professional athletes have ventured to
Bradenton Florida to train at IMG
Academy
in 2013 the facility which also serves
as an academic institution fielded its
first high school football team over the
past couple of seasons the IMG Academy
ascenders have stockpiled some of the
nation's top gridiron talent the main
reason why I came to be myself ready to
get my body right and not only mentally
but physically get prepared for college
and as well as academics I mean
academics here young there so many
resources we have two deserted here you
know from 7:00 in the morning all the
way to no 9 o'clock at night you talk
about G you talking about the best
preparation best facilities it gives me
best repair you know for the next level
facilities are second or not I mean some
of the federal most college campus I
venture all our coaches are full-time
football coaches our train is a
full-time training we got a nutritionist
full-time nutritionist
we have basically everything a top-tier
college has but we're in high school
because it's where you come to be great
it's a professional move to come here
when you talk about having the best
program you know you got some of the
best players in the country you know so
you notice that it gets kind of real out
there you know we don't hold anything
that we know we're the best competition
we're going to say no one of the
ascenders 5-star recruits is shaped
Patterson the nation's number one ranked
high school quarterback we've committed
to Ole Miss thing about shade that
stands out his ability to throw the
football you know he finds windows and
you know he gets in a rhythm but he's
really hard to stop what makes him
special in my opinion is the fact that
he can roll out of the pocket and still
be just as effective as if he's standing
in there you know use these literally
lightning in a bottle once he gets out
he gets running around our turn right we
have to be great on our returns right on
the holdups
if I'm the l0l my I have to get the
party started
okay butch his guy hits the Gatorade
containers okay get him out of there but
we're gonna return up there IMG
Academy's coaching staff has a combined
28 years of professional and collegiate
coaching experience we came down and
visit IMG I felt like it was a great
opportunity for my kids that come in get
an opportunity to have a great academic
experience athletically prepare
themselves you know lay the foundation
for their lives and you know their
future me playing professional ball you
know you got the experience about being
a player you inside the lines are being
a coach you outside the lunch I was
fortunate enough to be at Tampa Bay
starting with our head coach Tony Dungy
and then going to my defensive back
coach Herman
and one of the things he would always
say would be appropriate right ooh do
here is we're trying to have the best
student athlete I think winning young
athletes look at where I've been and
that's a it's a dream a goal for a lot
of them you know I can certainly speak
from experience knowing the challenges
that I went through in my career and
relate that to our young players having
guys who played in the National Football
League
that can speak to the journey that it
takes to get to that level
having that NFL pedigree is huge let's
go
halo-halo ernie Logan the defensive line
coach played for nine seasons in the NFL
under Bill Belichick Tom Coughlin and
Bill Parcells Ernie he has the presence
of a defensive lineman voice is very
deep to a boy he's a guy that our
defensive line not only can look up to
because he's played the position but
also they better get in line because
when he speaks everybody on the field
kid can hear him tag hey are you serious
what you think this flag football when
his favorite word is boss this ain't no
family show bones everything is boss
honor when he's talking to you is boss
are you a biscuit away your biscuit away
from 280 balls I think Ernie was
probably using the term ball sleigh
before it was really cool yeah you three
bills boss he's so bipolar as a
defensive line code like here be on you
one one second and then the next second
he makes you laugh with off-the-wall
jokes oh he say something he's a truck
here it is well good I get off on the
sidelines ball you fine
we do that drunk just woke up
it's about 9 a.m. heading to Walker's a
little bit tired this game day bag let's
go it's the third Saturday of August IMG
Academy's first opponent American
heritage the two-time reigning Florida
state champions what you got here she's
deaf
that's what they're saying they're
saying you're not about who's about to
pay for champions have you looked in the
mirror have you ever thought about
everybody else's perspective you think
they're scared that expects to win and
they expect to keep your tail full of
rich kids spoiled rich kids right that's
the perception you get everything you
don't know anything nobody knows what do
you lose jump back let's get crazy let's
play control passion win your back with
your back heading into their preseason
opener the ascenders would be without
their top defensive back LSU bound
five-star senior Savion Smith who would
miss the game due to a groin injury
atmosphere Yama
the lights come on the Showtime baby
they brought a flag and run through that
sonar field on our field they bring a
flag and run through it on our field hey
I got listen I swear everybody better go
watch you all night everybody King
everybody hey man let's go don't tell me
what to do
IMG Academy has dreams of being the best
team in the nation standing in their way
though American heritage the Patriots
have won two consecutive state
championships and we are underway
scrambles left finds a wide open you
baked in the end zone and American
heritage is on the board
hey Sam
American heritage Patriots with a seven
nothing lead at halftime over the fable
IMG Academy now then choose to play a
half together now we know what are we
about this is where you find out who
your leaders are this is where you find
out what type of team you are right now
one score one score you can't tell me we
don't have the guys that can take it to
the house
on any given play off its defense
special teams and make up that
difference we just got to do it find a
way win the football by the way win a
football game break it down let's go
roll out looking for the end zone as
Patterson and he waltzes in for the
first points of the season
you can see the mojo coming up a little
bit here for that IMG defense we alive
now baby
we allow be a dangerous thing when we
allow come on the play and it's
immediately scooped up ooh the football
we can reload it hey it's not over
right all right now you told me a play
and now they're gonna throw it in a
great catch mate down the sideline into
the end zone goes Brandon Johnson
so the Patriots take the lead but it's
only a six-point game almost over bi and
IMG will have about 85 yards to go
time to throw this time over the middle
big time catch 420 million and a lot of
a hitch ball is Charlie
AMG Academy needs to get into the end
zone
Patterson surveys the field finds
pressure rolls right lobs it to the end
zone it is caught for the game-winning
touchdown AMG storm in the field
flag on the field bolded I'll move not
anymore
come on man what
game on the line Patterson steps up to
avoid the pressure just brings it down
to the middle of the field in it
into the end zone
what a compressive job by the American
heritage Patriots you come here - hi
it's done a team that was ranked number
one in the max prep school that's a good
football team and again this is their
Super Bowl if we're not ready to execute
Oh this approach is players all this you
don't prepare of the ship you know
that's what happens another you're
saying that you can give me practice
after we good
you go from winning the game to all
those emotions mixed emotions to losing
it in just in 30 seconds so it's
definitely heartbreaking I actually
didn't know what they come here and all
my thoughts just like everybody else you
can't be the reason we should be beat
that game just show you know anybody can
be beat on any day coming away from it
feel like okay now we can roll up our
sleeves you got the kids attention I
mean no they just didn't roll out there
and all over somebody that changed
everybody's mindset 18 tell from the
coaching you know everybody focus dead
talk about all the time everybody is
true you're not here let's just handle
it first so just understand you're going
to have success
guys it's we're going to have success
how you handle success is it support is
how you handle is her not alright no man
you say nothing doing this every week
every week every week is not worth
ruining Matt I have I to be ready
everybody I feel like we're the best
tuna cruncher there's no doubt about
that
you